السلام عليكم
محمد مشهور الحجاج
والحج يكم عن احلام او حلم
اه
الموضوع المتعلق
بالكوميكس
بالتاريخ
بالخلود والانساني
القصه بدات
سؤالكم
ماده التاريخ في المدينه
هيذي القصه اذا كان ا بالضبط
في الفين وخمسه
كان اخواني بيشتكوا من المقرر بتاع
التاريخ بشكل مع طبيعي لكن
لما جينا على انه في اجازه نصف السنه
كلنا افلام
ومسلسلات بتقديم ماجد غيره لا غيره كان في
مسلسل بالتحديد
صقور الارض بيتكلم عن
[تصفيق]
المسلسل بيتكلم عن تاريخ الصين في فترات
انهيار الامبراطوريه
يتكلم عن
الكتاب الاساس اخوانك ان المحافظين عدد
العربات الحربيه اسمها جنيرالات عدد ال
كانت تتحرك من حسن الحظ واسماء الحصول على
رغم انها اسماء غريبه عليهم لما ان كانت
يفوتني حلقه كانوا بيسميها والا درس او
محاضره على التاريخ كامله الى مجرد انهم
شافوها في مسلسل بتاعته في اللحظه قيمه
بتاعت الكارتون كوسيله وصلنا المقرر بتاع
التاريخ
السودان
هل عندنا قصص صالحه انها تكون
قصص مصوره المتحركه الاجابه كانت نعم احنا
بلد عمرنا في تاريخ اكثر من مائه الف سنه
فيها اكثر من مائه لغه فينا اكثر من سبعه
حضارات متلاحقه مختلفه ومتنوعه
في القصه القصص الكثيره اللي كانت في قصه
مميزه ناس كثيرين بها اللي هي
الاسره 25 الفين وخمسه وعشرين جماعه
العارف الفائده
طيب بيتعرفوا
احكي لهم
الناس في عمري
بيعرفوا انه غزه ومصر عشان
لكن القصه الحقيقيه القصه الحقيقيه الفين
وسته هو سنتين كان بيحاول انه ما يحصل في
حروب مع الناس ال كان ويحتل الجزء الشمالي
من المملكه المتحده لكن بعد سنتين اضطراري
لما بدا في الحريري
الجنرالات الاربعه
اسماء الكلام ده كويس
اذهبوا انتم وجنودكم واسلحتهم فاغتسلوا في
النهر المقدس لكي لا يحارب في جيش الخطيئه
وعندما تصل الى ارض الاقداس الاقصر
الحاليه
ساكنيها يقولوا لهم نعم نحن لم نات الحرب
بل لاحلال السلام
وعندما تصل الى ارض العدو فكونوا بينهم
وبين محاصيلهم ولكن
لا تحرق المحاصيل لا تحرق الارض تتدمر
ولا تحارب وهم في الليل كنا بنحارب وهم في
وضح النهار وليكن قتالهم لهم برمي النيبال
لكي لا ينوي لكي لا يكون الموت كثيرا في
الطرفين وان اتى حلفائهم لنجدتهم
يخلوا بينهم وبين حلفائهم لان طعم
الانتصار على القوى الطيب وابقى اثرا من
الانتصار على الضعيف
وحين تم تصيرون
فلا تقتل جنديا واحدا لانهم كانوا مامورين
وان كنتم فاعلين ولا تفعلوا فاقتلوا
جنرالات والامراء لانهم كانوا سبب هذه
الحرب اللعينه
وانتصر يجمعهم
بعد الانتصار ارض احتلالها وكانت بتحتل
لسنوات طويله جدا خمسه
الناس كانت متوقعه يعمل اللي بيعملوا كله
محتل
بساطه بعدما تم يتاكد من السلام تم في
الارض في شمال الوادي فمنطقه بدلتها
الحصان وتوجهها على الجنوب الليبيين ال
هزم سكان شمال الوادي الاشوريين قالوا لو
بيتعاملوا قال جمله اثبتت انه النظريات
اللي تقال في اليونان احنا في افريقيا بين
حقيقه قال لسكان الارض احكموا نفسكم
بنفسكم
2700 سنه السوداني يحقق مفهوم الحكم
الذاتي
منو فيكم لما كان عمره 14 سنه 15 او 16
عنده فكره شديد لكن خايف يتكلم فيها يقول
وتغير
في الحاجات
ان كانت عندي يتكلم لكن بعد كلهم قالوا
صبر يتعلم وفهم لانه ال اكبر منك بيوم
اعلم منك بسنه
بس عشان عمره 15 او 16 سنه
حاجات واحلام وافكار تخطط عليها
الثاني نزول يقول حاجه جيدي ولوموا انفسكم
تبدو اباء وامهات
خليكم مذكرين
وهو عمره 16 سنه بس كان قايل لي جيوش وكان
حامي الحدود الشماليه للسودان وكان
الجنرال ال بيقدر
ضعف او ثلاثه اضعاف
حقيقه عملها
تاريخ الاسره خمسه وعشرين اللي حنا
في النهايه لما نتكلم عنه
تاريخ
بالرغم الانسانيه
لكن هو تعليق القاهره
منتصر ومن هذه الحاله هل في التاريخ بتاع
الاسره 25
حاجه او رساله او مضمون مخاطر انسانيتنا
صافيه
الاجابه نعم
الاجابه باسم احتمال تسمعوا اول مره
الليله اللي هو الامير خالد ابن
الامير خالد
اعتزل السياسه اعتقد الوالد وتوجه للعباده
ولما توفي اول من حسب ال مداري موت قدام
قصه انه يكتب على قبره الوصيه
ان يعني لا ادري
ولا اعتدى على امريكيه في غيره ويحسب
وامعانا في الفقراء
كله فقره في الوصيه بعد خالد
يتكلم بتوصلنا احساس الانسانيه والاحساس
الى اخر بس في الوصيه بحاجه جويه جدا مهمه
جدا
وتخدم معاكم داخلها المحاضره جدا
انه هو كان بيعمل في الحياه الدنيا دي كل
الحاجات الكويسه
للعالم الاخر عشان يكون البيئه المناره
للاحفاد الفيديو من بعده واللي بيبعد يهم
وللابد
كانت الوصيه ال احنا لازم نذكرها لازم
نحتفظ بها في ذهننا بتاع الخالق دولي 2700
سنه كان عندنا والنص الانسان اذا
فيه قصه شخصيه شويه
بعد الحماس اللي جيت ومن الخمسه وعشرين
وكميه من القصه القصه في تاريخ السودان
القديم والحديث
انت عملت الشركه سميتها تاسيس الانتاج
الاعلامي اللي هو واحد من اسماء السودان
الجديد وكان حققنا نجاح كبير جدا الاداريه
انه في اول شهور لينا في 2013 قدرنا ناخذ
تعمل بيهم اجلنا مصوره يتوزع للاطفال في
المتحف القومي بيصير
كان نجاح كبير جدا لان صوره توزع الفئه
العمريه اللي حنا مهتمين بها في المكان
الى هنا وصلنا المعلومات اللي هي تاريخ
السوداني للاطفال لكن بعدها اربعه شهور بس
الشركه على افلاس الشركه السعوديه انا
سافرت الامارات عشان نحاول نشوف فرص لانه
نتابع احلام في الامارات حصل اللي
صحي كبير في فتره اقل من شهر في يوم واحد
يعني نوبتين قلبين ازمه قلبيه
السودان لا ينفع الدكاتره في السودان
قالوا لي انه
تعمل عمليه وكل سنتين
العمليه دي عمليه ترميم
في حاله احباط انه اذار سيكون شكله كيف او
حياتي كيف
لكن في النهايه
وحاول اواصل يقول ما في حاجه باقي في عمري
اواصل في الفكره الثانيه فلم مجلس طريق
المستشارين كان ناس انا بحب اسمها كلام
اسمع اليوم يتكلموا بطريقه
تشويه لكن ب نوصل المعلومه لهما دايرين
والتنميه من مصالح بعرض عليها عليكم عندنا
في واحد
الثاني اذا ب دكتور
بالليل
لما تخترق قلب رصاصه ولا يموت فيها مرض
ولا يكون فتره لا الانسان في مثل ما نسميه
واكثر واحد في يوم بتاع مشاكل يستخدم
قالوا البشر اقوياء لانه عندهم القدره على
صنع مستقبلهم تغييره
المجلس والكلام اللي قالوا لي ان اخذ
الاداريه انه في شركه تماما في شركه يكون
بينقل ال المعلومه ال عنده بالكلمه في اي
حته سبحان الله النجاح في
تحقيق النجاح في مشروع
الحقيقه الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
مسبقا الرساله بتاعتي انه وصلكم ولو بالك
لما
كنت من الناس الا حاجه من تاريخ السودان
ليل نهار نهار وليل في اماكن مفتوحه مغلقه
واقول ان تعرف حضرتك فلانا بدات بالطريقه
دي
واكمل ونتعرف على مجلس المستشارين
[تصفيق]
انا سؤالي
اذا كان شخصيات خياليه من ثقافه ثانيه
قدرت تصاعد في انها انقذ حياتي يعني من
حاله تيار بتخليني غير في فكره انت شايفه
بشكل معين لانها تبقى باشكال ثانيه مختلفه
وتفيد ناس اكثر اذا كان الحاجه اللي حصلت
بالكائنات ال ما في اليها وجود طيب احنا
عملنا قصص مصوره ابطالها
الحقيقيين
خاليه وصلت ان ينتج الدين او بحر الدين
السلطان عجبنا والمهادي الاسر راح يكون
هناك شباب وفي اطفالنا في الاجيال
المتراكمه في مقارنه صغيره كانت ضعيفه انه
رايك ما هو الاسم القديم اللغه باعتقادي
النيه اللي هي ما سماه في احداث كثيره
الوراثيه لكن لما نقول
الاقامه في شكل رموز القصه الحاجه لذلك
مباشر بالقصه المصوره
يعني القصه المصوره في القرن الواحد
والعشرين احنا ممكن لما نكون كمان ضمنا
تاريخنا يمكن ان نسميها القرن الواحد يعيش
فيه
ايران كما كان قبل الفين وسبعمائه سنه ال
فيها خالد خطه وسيطه كانت حاجه انسانيه
اذا
كانت حاجه بانسانيه
لم خالد منتصر
على بلدان ثانيه اسمها غازي القاهره بعد
كله اذا خالد بانسان تم في السؤال ال انا
سالته لنفسي بطرحها عليكم واكيد عندكم
الاداره انه فيه انسان مره عليكم في حياته
شايف انه يستحق الخلود شايف انه انتوا
بالنسبه لي انا
بشكل شخصي جدا انا الانسان في حياتي في
فتره السنه الاخيره
يتوافقوا في يوم السلام اه ربما يقبلوا
ولم ان توفي ماقدرت اكتب اي شيء ما قدرت
ما قدرت اي حاجه
الشرطه القصير خالد زي ما هي وخطتها انا
حسيت انها هي بتمثل انه هو
خاليه هو نفسه من ناحيه انسانيه وهو شاهد
عبد القاد الى الحج
فقط الحكي يا ما كان احساس انه في
حاله خاصه جدا لانه هو كان
يساعد يظهر تم بيخلي الناس تمشي لقدام
بدون ما يسمى كان بيساعد بالتدريب كان
بيساعد بالتنفيذ حتى اول فيلم لي السحايا
في مهرجانات في العالم كله
وكانت تدريب واستضافه الفيديوهات و
الملفات الصوتيه الى ان تسمعوها في النبي
قال فيها حاجه التي نفذت بالمعدات بتاعه
شدي جيت انه انا اوصل في فيس بوك فيه وصيه
كفايه عليه
فقلت لنفسي
انه انا بكتفي قصص مصوره واحد اربعه
وثلاثين نقطه يحتل الانتاج
اختارت شخصيه انسانيه بتشبه شدي
وسميت الشخصيه والبطاله شي الحاج حسن
يفضل المستمر
الى سبعين سنه لدى المسؤولين في قلوب
[تصفيق]
قصص كثيره في المختصه واحده لكن في سؤال
تسميه تسميتها اليكم انه
تقوم بها وتاريخ وكونك
جديد القرن الواحد وعشرين
الذي كالعاده
السوداني
احنا
يتخطى فيه غالي عشان تبني عتبات السنين
يوصل الاجيال الجايه لمستقبل احسن
المرحوم شاهدا على خياره انه هو حبه الرمي
اللي بتختلف مع حبات قنبله ثانيه
عشان تكون العتب ادى عشان تعمل السانده
سنتوصل الى اجيال جايه المستقبل احسن
في حبات رمل وترفض الحته اللي بتقول انه
هي مميزه انه هي ما فيه
بنفسها بس
لديه بساطه شديده الانانيه الهواء اتصل
لاحظنا تكون في عيون الاجيال الجايه تحميل
يشوفوا مستقبلهم بشكل كويس
نظره للامور معها تعمل حاجه الله يختار
يكون يعطي نوع من الرمل وانا في طريق
واخيرا تكون يتنامى انا اقول
ببساطه محبه ال مترابطه مع اخوانه عشان
اختياري انا خليكم ان تم اختيارهم عاوزين
تكون حبهم منفرده بتازيم ولا حبها مجتمع
بتبني مستقبل اخليكم مع الاختيار واشكركم
[تصفيق]
ام